hey welcome to a new project calm video
so in this video i'm gonna give you guys
an update on the plastic roof we
installed a few videos ago
didn't really work out as we thought it
would and also gonna give you an update
on a team member that is working here
you guys are asking to show a little bit
more of the people behind the project
and finally we also started renovating
this rune here and taking off the roof
so i'm gonna show you how that's done
have fun
so here we have a little ruin which is
going to be a future guest house but
also our warm place for the winter
but in order to make it warm we still
have some things to do
and so we're going to start the
renovation work but uh before we're
gonna start i wanna show you guys the
current state which is in now because
this is really the last time we're gonna
see it like this
so the main thing about this rune is
that it's
granite
and bricks this was the old part and
through our time they rebuild it
add things to it which makes it a bit
messy
but here it's now a very the granite
area it's a very cool area super thick
granite
also not very well built for a granite
building there are better examples out
there but it functions
and later on
they rebuilt here this area or added the
wall so it's a mix of bricks and granite
so another room here
the floor is added later and the floor
itself or the roof is still pretty
stable and doable
to reuse it's also leaning on the
granite which makes it sturdy except
here here is leaning on the bricks which
is not structurally proper so we need to
reinforce it here to make sure the floor
is actually leaning
on strong areas
and
yeah and so
the bottom is still pretty good
if we manage to renovate it a bit
reinforce that part we can reuse the
whole bottom and the floor that is on
top which is good
the top part is a bit more dubious we're
not really sure yet what to do
and the main reason is because
on the one hand the building is built in
quite a rough way
but also it burned down here a few years
ago so some bricks with the heat lost a
bit of their strength
so the mix of those two things makes
this building not super
robust
uh so as you can see for instance here
like this hinge
it's really just very roughly put in
here
here there's a piece of boot
which is just molded with cement in
there
here you can see the shelf which is just
with cement put between the
wall so yeah not very conscious proper
way of building
and the roof itself and the walls are
somewhat
collapsing and falling apart
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to take off the roof tiles take
off the wooden beams on top
remove all the parts that are somewhat
falling take out this wall
and then we're going to analyze again to
see what to do next because we still
have this main question whether we can
reuse the existing walls
because it would save a lot of bricks
that otherwise we have to replace with a
new material or we really have to take
off the whole top part and build
something new
so yeah we can start taking it down and
see
what it's going to look like what we're
going to find out
so maybe you've noticed the guy hanging
in the mimosa tree in the last shot it's
our good friend tim from south africa
who came to help us out
you know what let me just get him here
so he can say hello hi there i'm tim a
27 year old climber highliner product
designer from johannesburg south africa
and i'm here for just over a month to
help out
i work together with dave in eindhoven
on precious plastic version 4.
precious plastic is an open source
project based on boosting plastic
recycling all around the world
maybe you've also seen in the previous
episodes that we build the roofs here
with recycled plastic sheets those were
made with some of the open source
techniques you will see later in the
video an update on this one too
if you'd like to know more about
precious plastic just go to
preciousplastic.com or just search it in
youtube
so since i climbed and highlined for
many years i'm quite comfortable with
heights as you will see soon
i'm also super familiar with ropes
rigging and gear so one of the first
things i did here was to install the big
yellow top over the workshop so that we
can work here in summer without getting
fully baked by the sun
this is the top um it's not ideal
there's still a bit of droop in the
middle
um but i think that's just because of
the weight of the plastic itself
still a bit rough
but i think we did the best we could
with what there is and we'll
work on it as as time goes by
enjoy the rest of the video
so since we had to start somewhere with
the renovation of the rune we set our
first goal on dismantling the rotten
roof to make sure it doesn't fall on our
head later
and most of the roof tiles are actually
still okay and it should be good to use
somewhere in the future so we tried to
save them not sure how to reach all of
them or how to even cut down these huge
wooden beams but yeah let's
[Music]
[Music]
i've heard see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
how is it up there
feels pretty good
old and moldy i can't see what's
underneath so it makes me feel a bit
better is it windy
a little windy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good job
hey
[Music]
snake
so we've just finished taking the tiles
off the roof and next we're gonna think
about how we attack the wood
how was it up there like windy a little
windy
very low kind of squatting the whole
time but it was fun
quite used to it because you climb
anyway a lot right yeah i climb
i like to be on a subway high yeah
well you choose for that as well see
climber shoes ah they're approach shoes
so they like have some sticky rubber
flip that around
the thing yeah yeah it's hard to get in
there
um
so what's the plan guys for the
afternoon
i'm gonna try to get the wood off and
maybe we
crow the like the whole sheet off as one
unit and then slide it off the building
like down there to the left yeah
if it comes off as
one otherwise we do it slowly
oh we just cut it
but i think you see
yeah those are already half this is yeah
it's half at the beam
which is manageable
i think
we have a big stick
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
milk
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right so the plan is to push over
this wall and
if we're lucky the cement will detach
and we'll have
50 perfect bricks
if we're unlucky the whole wall will
fall down and the whole ruin will
collapse
not ideal
almost
you can feel everything shaking 50 good
bricks
nice
all right so the roof is now off it's
just a brick structure here
downside a bit with these bricks is that
they're not very strong and the cement
is actually harder so it's very hard to
detect them from each other
so we're now thinking and what to do
with all the bricks do we keep the walls
or not
it's kind of difficult because for
instance this wall uh before it had
support from all the beams from the roof
but now that support is gone and also it
has a lot of holes on the bottom and
that whole corner there is just not
attached so i could just push over this
whole wall
so i'm not sure if it makes sense to
fully remove it uh it would be the
easiest option but we also kind of
don't like throwing all these bricks out
which would probably be the outcome of
that
so yeah let us know if you have any
suggestions or ids on what to do with
this could use some inspiration
and in general make sure to check out
the research module if you want to
follow this process we will
keep you posted there
as you might remember during last season
we built a recycled plastic shade roof
this was built with recycled plastic
sheets made out of polypropylene
for giving us a bit of shade and protect
us from the rain during winter but
was not going perfect until now
many of you already mentioned that this
roof would leak in the future the
overlap is not enough plastic sheets
were not chilling
so yeah i can tell you it looks
boring
so
what we tried so far is to shield in the
overlapping of the sheets
still not really working
because the
sheet warps too much sealant is not
enough we still don't figure out what
it's gonna be
but we will keep on upgrading the roof
until it starts to leak because this is
quite boring
so we can keep you updated in the
research model in spraycam.com
so to try to solve the leaking problem
we have added some
bootil in the overlapping butyl is a
kind of
silicon that doesn't dry ever and
doesn't stick to the plastic so we can
always remove it afterwards in case we
need to reuse the sheets
still was not solving the leaking
problem so we added an extra layer of
polymer on top of the
edges
to
try we can get rid of the leaks
still not possible
so one of the big problems of working
with recycled plastic sheets in the sun
and in outside conditions is that as you
can see the plastic warps a lot so
there's a lot of tension in the sheets
which make us not really
able to add the screws the screws break
always plastic is every day moving when
it's sunrise plastic start to move we
need to start to be colder plastic keeps
on moving
so it's like a live
roof now
scissors is still an ongoing project
so let's see how it behaves we will keep
you updated in the research model
but so far we are not really convinced
yet since it's leaking all this warping
in the plastic is not super fun
so
probably the problem can come from the
design itself
we will still keep on going keep on
upgrading to make it waterproof so
that's how it goes
[Music]
alright so that was it for this video we
now have the roon ready for renovation a
lot of work to be done it's exciting if
you want to help out you can go to the
website and sign up
or just keep watching these videos and
then you'll see how it's going to evolve
that was it for this week but next week
we actually got a nice gift from our
neighbors which involves a lot of water
falling from a high distance we can see
more about that next week
if you already want to see that video
make sure to support on patreon if not
you'll just see it next week here on
youtube and also yeah thank you for
watching all these youtube videos the
channel has been growing a lot which is
really cool keeps us motivated so thank
you and see you next week
[Music]
you